J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez, vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Mais bonjour, on ne va pas se le cacher, l'actualité a été dure cette semaine, violente même. Je...
Je n'ai pas les mots. Je pense qu'on aura l'occasion dans les années qui suivent de creuser en long et en large ce qui s'est passé cette semaine quand les Américains ont voté massivement pour Donald Trump, plus nombreux encore qu'en 2016.
C'est dur à croire. Clairement, moi, j'ai toujours pas encaissé, mais on tient le coup. Cette semaine, j'ai interviewé deux auteurs, autrices belges, à commencer par Suzanne Aubinet, qui nous arrive de Liège avec son premier roman Entre deux rives.
Suzanne est psychologue, travaille avec les services d'aide à l'enfance et se spécialise notamment sur les questions de violence sexuelle entre mineurs et de placement d'enfants en internat.
Ce sont des sujets lourds, donc soyez avertis, mais un peu comme quand on avait parlé de paraphilie et de pédophilie avec Pierre Oswald il y a quelques années, vous allez voir que la discussion n'est pas du tout explicite.
Ça reste écoutable, même si c'est des sujets lourds. On reste en surface et on explore ensemble ces questions qui sont largement inconnues du grand public.
Bonne écoute. J'ai le plaisir d'être aujourd'hui avec Suzanne Aubinet. Bonjour Suzanne.
Bonjour.
Suzanne, donc tu es psychologue clinicienne, tu nous viens de Liège. Tu travailles au service d'aide à la jeunesse en particulier.
Je travaille avec les enfants de l'aide à la jeunesse, mais je travaille pas pour le service...
Ah d'accord, tu travailles pas pour ce service, mais tu, tu es en collaboration avec ce service-là.
Ouais.
Et donc, il y a, voilà, chez toi une fibre sociale très importante. Ça se sent dans ton premier livre, qui s'appelle Entre deux rives chez Parla éditions, qui est donc ton premier roman qui vient de sortir.
Donc voilà, je le disais, c'est très présent dans ton roman, on y reviendra. C'est pas présent dans ton roman, mais tu es également spécialisée, entre autres, sur les questions des abus sexuels,
chez les mineurs et sur le placement des mineurs en internat.
Est-ce que j'ai oublié quelque chose dans cette longue présentation ?
Je ne sais pas. C'est difficile. Je travaille aussi, j'ai eu l'occasion de travailler avec les équipes qui s'occupent des enfants placés en internat ou victimes de violence.
Donc ça aussi, c'est une corde. Donc, je travaille avec les professionnels. Et puis, j'ai aussi l'occasion de travailler avec tout un tas d'autres enfants qui sont pas spécialement...
Mmm-hmm.
Placés ou victimes de maltraitance ou violence.
Juste, voilà, dans un cadre plus large de psychologue clinicienne.
Ouais, ouais.
Ouais, ouais. Mais du coup, j'ai envie de te poser la question : qu'est-ce qui t'a amenée, en fait, vers ces sujets ?
Parce que c'est quand même des sujets relativement sombres.
Oui.
C'est pas super guilleret.
Oui. Alors, donc en fait, moi, j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à la question, en tout cas, surtout des enfants placés,
et de la question de l'attachement chez ces enfants-là, quand j'ai débuté mes toutes premières études, qui étaient des études d'éducateur spécialisé, donc il y a 20 ans maintenant.
Mmm-hmm.
Donc j'ai travaillé tout de suite dans des institutions, en fait, où ces enfants étaient placés. Donc j'étais déjà fort en question par rapport à leur rapport à la relation.
Donc déjà, j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à ça. Et puis, lorsque j'étais en master, alors à l'université en psychoclinique, j'ai,
j'ai travaillé dans des hôpitaux et donc j'ai eu l'occasion d'être confrontée, en fait, en tant que professionnelle, à une situation de violence sexuelle entre mineurs. Donc...
Ok. Donc dans le cadre de ton travail.
Dans le cadre de mon travail au sein de l'hôpital. Donc voilà, en forme de, voilà, de laboratoire in vivo.
Mmm-hmm. Ouais.
Et donc, c'était une situation qui était à la fois extrêmement choquante et en même temps très très questionnante.
Et donc, voilà, a commencé à ce moment-là vraiment ma réflexion et j'ai voulu me pencher alors sur l'analyse de ces situations.
Qu'est-ce qui fait que les enfants arrivent à être dans ce type de situation, qu'ils soient auteurs ou victimes ?
Ouais.
Donc ça a commencé...
Ce que j'ai dit, donc chez les mineurs, mais c'est vraiment entre mineurs...
Entre mineurs.
Ta spécialisation.
Oui.
Et donc, on parle alors dans le cadre de la situation que tu as observée, c'est des mineurs de quel âge à peu près ?
Alors là, dans cette situation-là, on était sur un jeune de 13 ans et une jeune de 7 ans.
Oh, ok.
Voilà. Mais sinon, ce sont des situations qui sont extrêmement courantes dans les institutions de l'aide à la jeunesse ou les communautés de vie où se retrouvent les enfants, les écoles, les scouts, etc.
Et ça brasse tous les âges, quoi.
Donc, on va traverser, hein, toutes ces questions qui sont, voilà, je vais dire relativement sombres, mais qui en même temps, je pense, sont très intéressantes parce que c'est des sujets dont on entend parler.
On a rarement l'occasion de se pencher dessus. C'est-à-dire les placements dans les internats, les questions de ce que c'est de vivre dans ces institutions-là.
Voilà, c'est des choses dont on entend parler de loin, mais rarement on a l'occasion de s'y plonger. Donc vraiment, je pense que ça va être l'occasion de faire ça aujourd'hui.
Avant ça, je vais poser une question très intimidante.
Ah.
Je sais que ce n'est pas une question qui est particulièrement facile, mais je vais te le demander. Si il fallait, voilà... Qu'est-ce qu'il faut savoir sur ton histoire, sur ton parcours,
pour vraiment comprendre qui est Suzanne Aubinet ?
Qu'est-ce qui fait que tu es toi ?
C'est bien parce que je m'attendais pas du tout à cette question, donc...
J'étais pas prêt non plus.
J'ai pas réfléchi. Qu'est-ce qu'il faut savoir ? Bon, c'est clair que...
Ça peut être un événement en particulier, ça peut être, voilà, une phase de ton parcours, plein de choses.
Alors, j'ai envie de dire deux choses.
Alors, la première chose, et c'est quelque chose que je ne m'explique pas, parce que évidemment, on travaille un peu en circuit court entre psy, donc on fait beaucoup de thérapie nous-mêmes.
Et donc il y a des questions que je n'ai pas encore complètement résolues qui est : pourquoi est-ce que tu travailles aux côtés d'enfants ?
Mais je sais que depuis toute petite, il y avait un livre que j'adorais quand j'étais petite, qui était un album jeunesse qui s'appelait Madeleine.
Et c'est l'histoire de petites filles qui sont dans un internat à Paris dans les années 1910. Et je me rappelle que j'ai toujours dit : « Je veux être la madame qui s'occupe des petites filles », quoi.
Depuis toute petite, j'avais cette espèce de rêve, de me dire : moi, j'ai envie de travailler dans ce genre de structure, quoi.
Et alors, c'est marrant parce que pendant très très longtemps, je n'ai jamais retrouvé ce livre. J'avais toujours dit : j'ai l'impression qu'il y avait des petites filles avec des chapeaux.
Enfin, je n'ai jamais retrouvé ce livre. Et cet été, je suis avec ma mère au musée d'Orsay à Paris.
Et là, on est dans la boutique de souvenirs et elle me dit : « Oh, c'est celui-là ! » Et c'était celui-là. Et on a retrouvé Madeleine, le livre.
Ça, c'était marrant. Et donc c'est quelque chose qui m'habite depuis toute petite.
Et il parle de quoi, ce livre ?
Bah, c'est simplement l'histoire d'un rang de petites filles qui est dans un orphelinat dans les années 1900.
Et elles mangent ensemble, elles vont à l'école. Et puis à un moment, Madeleine, elle a une crise d'appendicite.
Et alors, la madame qui s'occupe d'elle, elle appelle l'ambulance et puis elle va à l'hôpital et puis elle revient et c'est fini.
Donc c'est vraiment un petit livre, mais je ne sais pas, une forme d'ambiance.
Rien de choquant dans l'histoire ?
Non, rien de... non, non, non, pas de trauma associé. Juste, je ne suis pas un adepte...
Je sais les relier avec tout ça. Vas-y, explique.
C'était plutôt l'ambiance. Moi, j'adorais quand j'étais petite, faire des hôpitaux avec tous mes Playmobils, des lits.
Voilà, donc vraiment dans un truc maison quoi, communauté. Voilà, je jouais à ça. C'était quelque chose qui m'attirait.
Et donc de manière générale, les institutions...
Les institutions.
Dans un cadre social...
Là, bah, dans mes jeux quand j'étais petite, voilà, c'était...
Les hôpitaux.
Des hôpitaux, des orphelinats quoi, vraiment. Donc des lieux de vie de communauté d'enfants, quelque chose comme ça.
Être l'adulte qui prend soin de ces enfants qui sont...
D'accord, OK.
Finalement obligés de vivre dans ces lieux de communauté, quoi. Donc ça, c'est une chose que j'ai l'impression d'avoir depuis vraiment toute petite.
Et une autre chose, par rapport au travail sur la violence sexuelle entre mineurs, c'est aussi quelque chose qu'il a fallu...
C'est marrant parce que vraiment, on a des grandes révélations après quinze ans de thérapie alors que c'est un peu évident.
On en a pour ça. C'est une thérapie, je te l'ai pas encore dit, mais...
C'est que, effectivement, moi, à l'âge de seize ans, j'ai eu une relation avec un garçon de mon école qui est une relation qui s'est avérée violente.
OK.
Et donc, voilà, je pense qu'il y a eu beaucoup de... 'fin, d'abord beaucoup de déni et puis,
et puis petit à petit, je pense que ça a sûrement guidé effectivement mon envie de comprendre les mécanismes, qui soient à la fois psychologiques,
individuels, dans le chef de l'enfant qui agresse ou de l'enfant qui subit, mais aussi au niveau institutionnel et au niveau sociétal.
Qu'est-ce qui fait qu'il est possible que ce type de relation puisse avoir lieu et pignon sur rue, quoi, quelque part.
Voilà. Et donc...
Se dérouler entre le moment où, donc, tu as subi ces violences et le moment où t'as un petit peu... t'as fait une rétrospective là-dessus où t'as pu comprendre un petit peu, ouais, en rétrospective ce qui a pu se passer.
Le comprendre, le : « Ah, c'était ça. »
Ouais, ça a pris quoi, dix ans ?
Je sais pas, vingt.
Vingt ans ? Ah oui. Donc c'est maintenant.
Non, sans avoir publié des articles sur le sujet. Sinon, c'est pas drôle. Quelque part, je le savais, mais à un jour, tu dis...
Est-ce que tu dirais que c'est fait ou est-ce que t'as toujours, t'as toujours...
Comment ?
Est-ce que tu dirais que c'est fait accompli ou bien est-ce que t'as toujours encore des choses à comprendre ?
Je crois qu'on est dans l'analyse et la compréhension de cette problématique, on est nulle part pour le moment.
En tout cas, je pense qu'il y a très peu de choses qui sont faites.
Tu veux dire de manière générale, nous, collectivement, en tant que société ?
Oui, c'est ça. Non, non, je veux dire au niveau de la société, au niveau même... 'fin nulle part. On n'est pas très très loin quoi, en termes de découvertes,
voilà, et de réflexions théoriques sur la question des violences entre mineurs.
C'est pas du tout un sujet qu'on aborde quoi, c'est un sujet qui est extrêmement silencié, comme toutes les violences sexuelles.
Donc je pense qu'on en a pas du tout fini. Voilà, qu'il y a encore plein plein plein de choses à faire.
Mh. Et donc c'est, voilà, à travers ce cheminement que tu as fait donc sur vingt ans, que donc tu as commencé à... voilà, t'as fait tes études donc en psychologie.
Oui.
Tu as publié des publications, on va revenir là-dessus, mais des liens entre les passages, l'acte de violence sexuelle, en particulier dans le cadre des personnes borderline, si j'ai bien compris, ou ?
Oh oui, oh oui, cet article-là, oui, ça, c'était mon travail de mémoire, alors, de master de psycho. Voilà, donc...
Donc on parle bien des personnes avec un trouble borderline ?
Ah non. Non.
Ah oui, mais le mot borderline, il a un petit peu tendance à surgir un peu partout, mais donc c'est pas ça, OK.
C'est les gens qui vont régresser en fonctionnement borderline.
Donc fonctionnement borderline, c'est pas la même chose qu'un trouble borderline.
Non.
OK.
Mais bon, ça se manifeste de la même manière, mais c'est... Donc... ah oui, oui, donc c'est... Ouais, ouais, ouais. OK, ouais, ouais.
Tu as des recherches dans ce cas-là.
Oui, oui, oui, je vois bien parce que ouais.
J'ai ouvert ta page LinkedIn, c'est tout.
Ouais, ouais, c'est ça, j'ai regardé.
Donc effectivement oui, j'ai écrit un article d'ailleurs, c'est super intéressant parce que je... un article qui a un nom absolument à coucher dehors et qui est incompréhensible hein,
et qui en plus passe complètement sous les radars des moteurs de recherche vu qu'il est pas du tout référencé comme traitant de la violence sexuelle entre mineurs.
Donc ça aussi, je trouve ça très intéressant de se dire comment est-ce qu'en 2012, finalement, ben,
il m'a été demandé de mettre ce titre qui est vraiment, voilà, c'est Étude d'une dyade régressée en fonctionnement borderline caractérisée par un passage à l'acte d'ordre sexuel. Incompréhensible.
Très académique.
Très, très académique.
On t'a demandé de mettre ça. T'aurais voulu l'appeler comment toi ?
Ah ben, je ne savais pas, mais moi, j'aurais mis un truc beaucoup plus...
Plus clicbait, un truc qui est mieux référencé.
Ouais, par exemple, je me rappelle que mon mémoire au CFL, donc quand j'étudiais pour devenir éducatrice spécialisée, il s'appelait Non.
Voilà, par exemple. Je travaillais sur la question de la limite chez les enfants.
Ok.
Et l'article d'après s'appelle Enfants placés, pas tout à fait. Donc voilà, donc quelque chose qui est beaucoup plus, voilà.
Pas étude d'une dyade machin machin. Mais je trouve ça intéressant parce que, voilà, par rapport à cette thématique, on va aller mettre un titre, voilà.
Mais bon, tout ça pour parler de la régression en fonctionnement borderline. Mon idée à l'époque, c'était qu'est-ce qui fait que ces enfants se retrouvent quelque part au sein d'une relation qui va générer un passage à l'acte ?
Mh.
Est-ce que c'est n'importe qui qui va se retrouver avec n'importe qui dans ce type de relation qui fait qu'il va avoir passage à l'acte ?
Donc est-ce que c'est une question de situation sociale ? Est-ce que c'est une question...
Alors, entre autres. Donc ce concept de régression en fonctionnement borderline de Luigi Cancrini, qui est un psychanalyste et systémicien italien,
va à la fois, et c'est ça qui est vraiment intéressant, je trouvais, comme concept, va à la fois associer le contexte social, mais surtout le passé de violence que l'enfant aurait vécu dans son passé
et également les caractéristiques du milieu dans l'ici et maintenant.
Et donc si un enfant va par exemple subir des maltraitances, des abandons, des choses qui ont pu générer chez lui des types de
de marques traumatiques, s'ils sont confrontés dans un contexte particulier à un stress, ça peut raviver
un mode de fonctionnement qui est assimilable au fonctionnement borderline.
Et mon hypothèse était que l'auteur comme la victime, c'est ça qui se passait, qui faisait qu'ils allaient se retrouver dans une relation qui allait pouvoir amener un passage à l'acte.
Et donc...
C'est un peu technique.
De manière alors très éphémère. Donc on ne parle pas d'une personne qui développe un trouble de la personnalité borderline, c'est un comportement de façon temporaire.
Voilà, ça, c'était l'idée, parce que ce sont des enfants.
Personne avec un trouble borderline.
Voilà, et ce sont des enfants. Donc effectivement, on ne peut pas diagnostiquer un trouble de la personnalité, de toute façon, chez des enfants, chez des mineurs.
Maintenant, cet auteur-là parle, pardon, parle d'un seuil de régression. Et donc effectivement, on peut avoir un seuil qui est bas, donc ça veut dire qu'il faut un stress très intense pour qu'on arrive à fonctionner de cette manière-là.
Mais il y a des gens qui ont des seuils très élevés, qui fait qu'un rien, pouf, va les faire fonctionner de cette manière-là.
Et donc effectivement, les gens qui ont un trouble de personnalité borderline, pour cet auteur-là en tout cas, ont un seuil qui fait qu'il se déclenche tout de suite.
En fait, je cherche à voir le lien entre... parce que je connais, j'ai connu des personnes qui ont un trouble de la personnalité borderline.
Je suis pas certain de voir le lien entre les agressions sexuelles
Ouais.
et le fait d'avoir une personnalité ou une personnalité qui évoque un
Oui, alors...
trouble de la personnalité borderline.
Évidemment. Oui, oui. Alors déjà, c'est des recherches que j'ai faites, avec lesquelles je suis plus complètement en accord, déjà, hein, parce que...
Oui, on a beaucoup évolué sur les questions un petit peu de troubles de la personnalité, de l'ordre de la société, tout ça.
Et en plus, je trouve que cette
cette recherche était vraiment dans une logique presque exclusivement psychologisante, qui est pas quelque chose avec lequel je suis en accord aujourd'hui dans la réflexion autour des situations de violence sexuelle.
Donc il y a une absence de politique.
Oui, tout à fait. Ou de...
Et par exemple, donc je suis venue vraiment étayer,
l'hypothèse, effectivement, que je n'utilise plus, hein, de cette régression en fonctionnement borderline avec tout le concept, évidemment, de domination et de symptômes psychiatriques associés au trauma.
Par après alors.
Par après, ouais. Donc quinze ans plus tard.
Ok, et en rétrospective alors, qu'est-ce que tu penses ? Comment est-ce que tu juges cette approche-là, très psychologisante, de, voilà...
Mais...
On va juger les agresseurs sexuels comme étant, voilà, des personnes borderline, etc. Comment est-ce que tu juges cette approche-là ?
Alors déjà, moi, dans mon idée de recherche, c'était, mon hypothèse étant que les enfants étaient mus l'un et l'autre par le même fonctionnement, la victime comme l'agresseur.
Et donc, ce que je garderais, c'est que je pense effectivement que des vécus traumatiques associés à de la maltraitance, à de la violence sexuelle, à des abandons, à de la négligence, est un facteur de risque de
de vivre à nouveau de la violence sexuelle, ou de la perpétrer.
Ouais.
Ça, c'est quelque chose que je garde.
Donc on est vraiment dans l'idée de... c'est presque de la psychologie sociale quoi, c'est presque l'environnement dans lequel on évolue peut amener certains comportements.
Moi, c'est effectivement quand je rencontre les enfants de l'aide à la jeunesse qui malheureusement ont traversé des contextes de vie qui sont extrêmement difficiles, les répercussions psychologiques sont là.
Ouais, ouais, c'est ça.
Voilà, c'est...
Et, mais donc qu'est-ce qui fait que tu as envie de te distancier de cette approche-là ? Donc il y a l'absence de politique.
Oui.
Mais j'avais l'impression de détecter aussi peut-être une approche très psychanalyse
psychanalyste, etc.
Alors oui, je pense effectivement que dans une logique psychologisante de la compréhension des phénomènes, voilà, comme ceux-là, peuvent amener vraiment quelque chose de très culpabilisant, que ce soit pour la victime...
Et pour l'enfant agresseur, même si effectivement, il faut, bah, jamais le dédouaner de sa responsabilité, quant aux actes qu'il commet.
Mais pour les victimes aussi, combien de fois est-ce qu'on n'entend pas que des femmes victimes qui arrivent et qui veulent travailler sur leur traumatisme,
voilà, avec une approche plus psychanalytique, on peut mettre
un sens assez culpabilisant sur les traumas.
Oui. Je... alors, j'ai oublié de préciser, mais nous sommes dans une maison très anti-psychanalyse.
Ok, ok.
Mais je sais pas, donc tu as laissé tout ça derrière toi et maintenant, tu es plutôt dans une approche politique.
Non, non.
Non ? Il reste encore un peu de psychanalyse, alors ?
Oui, bah alors, moi, je trouve que, voilà...
Il reste un peu de Freud dans ton cerveau.
On va peut-être se disputer, mais voilà. Il y a... Moi, j'ai jamais déjà envie de dire : « Je rejette tout ça et je prends pas ».
Parce que je trouve que ça nourrit plein de réflexions. Et donc je me dis que c'est toujours intéressant de remettre dessus.
Au niveau de l'histoire de la psychologie, ouais.
Et voilà, je ne sais pas comment dire. J'ai un rapport ambigu à Freud. C'est sûrement parce que c'est Freud.
Mais il y a des choses... Voilà, je trouve quand... par exemple, il écrit très bien, il y a quand même un déroulé de pensée qui est quand même vraiment intéressant, mais il y a vraiment des choses, plus ça va, moins je suis d'accord.
Mmh.
Par exemple, aborder la question du complexe d'Œdipe avec des enfants incestés, je veux dire, c'est quand même très très limite, quoi. 'Fin, donc voilà.
Oui, mais, ouais. En fait, bon, on va, alors, on va vite refermer cette parenthèse sur la psychanalyse.
Touchy.
Mais pour résumer ça, moi, j'aurais tendance à dire que c'est juste quelque chose qui se revendique comme n'étant pas de la science.
Et dans le cadre de la science psychologique, je trouve qu'il y a une, voilà, une incompatibilité entre quelque chose qui est très...
On ne sait pas très bien d'où ça sort, hein, cette idée du complexe d'Œdipe. Ça vient un petit peu de l'invention de Freud, il a décidé ça un jour et voilà.
Oui. Et en même temps, c'est marrant parce que c'est vrai que moi, dans la manière avec laquelle je vais pratiquer la psycho
Mmh
en entretien ou... donc j'ai, par exemple, une manière de travailler très intuitive. Donc, par exemple, je vais pas être quelqu'un qui va aller, voilà, faire passer des batteries de tests ou
aller utiliser telle et telle chose plus rigoureuse.
Mmh.
Ça, c'est le grand débat, hein, en psycho, évidemment, voilà, les neurosciences, la psychoclinique
Dans le cadre de la psychologie clinicienne, effectivement, je comprends qu'on fasse l'intuitif, mais effectivement, quand il s'agit de poser
des diagnostics, d'expliquer des phénomènes, de dire : « Voilà ce qui t'est arrivé, voilà pourquoi », etc.
Si on va chercher dans la psychanalyse, moi, je trouve que c'est très grave en fait, parce que c'est
Parce qu'il y a quelque chose... bah, il y a quelque chose de déterministe, voilà, qui pose vraiment question.
Maintenant, par exemple
La psychologie sociale est déterministe aussi.
Oui. Mais dans la question, par exemple, du concept de Cancrini, là, sur la régression en fonctionnement borderline, il allie à la fois l'ici et maintenant, le passé et des caractéristiques comportementales.
Et donc là, à partir du moment où on ouvre le spectre et qu'on l'insère dans un contexte, alors on peut éviter les écueils déterministes et parfois qu'attaquent, que propose la psychanalyse.
Oui, oui. Donc ça, c'est donc sur la question du... Alors, j'ai oublié le titre très très long de ton article.
La dyade bla bla bla, là.
Oui, c'est ça.
Oui, c'est ça. Vous pouvez tous aller regarder, hein, c'est sur Google.
C'est ça. Mais donc, voilà, ça, tu l'as fait en 2013, hein, si je me souviens bien.
Ouais, c'est la suite de... c'est mon travail de fin d'études de master, ouais.
C'est ça.
Qui a été publié, ouais.
Et donc il y a eu également donc d'autres publications que tu as faites depuis.
Ouais.
Plus récemment, en 2022, tu parles, dans le cadre de l'enfance, tu as publié un article qui s'appelle : « Et si lire, c'était désobéir ? »
Ah oui !
Pour parler de l'enfance soumise.
Ah ouais.
Ça, je veux bien que tu nous parles.
Alors, mais c'est pas du tout l'enfance soumise. C'est la littérature insoumise.
Alors, dans le pitch de ton truc, il y a écrit « enfance soumise ».
Ah oui, non. Alors, c'est donc des travaux que j'ai faits donc sur la littérature jeunesse.
« Peut-on tout lire aux enfants ? » Donc je sais pas, à mon avis, il manque des mots, je ne sais pas ce qui se passe, mais en fait, c'est
Je vais te retrouver ça très vite.
C'est un, oui, un article qui s'appelle effectivement : « Peut-on tout lire aux enfants ? » Et ça travaille sur la question de la censure de l'adulte dans les choix des albums jeunesse qu'on lit aux enfants.
Oui.
Donc ça, là, on part sur vraiment autre chose.
Oui, tout à fait, oui. Mais on va faire le lien, t'inquiète, c'est
Et donc ça, c'est plutôt un plaidoyer pour l'intelligence de l'enfant et pour la littérature jeunesse de qualité.
Mmh. Oui, puisque donc on part du principe que, par exemple, les contes de fées développent des idées, forment les pensées, des modes de fonctionnement chez les enfants.
Enfin, oui, les histoires qu'on va leur lire, les films qu'on va leur exposer, etc.
Ouais.
Et donc, oui, mais quel est le propos que tu développes exactement par rapport à ça ?
Donc moi, j'ai travaillé ça avec une amie qui est experte en littérature jeunesse et libraire.
Et on voulait approfondir la question des thématiques que les adultes pourraient décider de ne pas lire aux enfants.
Donc les thématiques qui vont traiter de la mort, de l'anxiété, du suicide, de la mélancolie, des peurs, des angoisses.
Voilà, on avait fait un petit panel tout en disant que nous, on pensait effectivement que c'était absolument des thématiques à pouvoir développer avec les enfants
et que, dès petits, ils puissent avoir accès à des albums qui vont traiter de ce type de thématiques.
Et on voulait aussi proposer une alternative à ce qu'on appelle le livre médicament qui fait qu'on va dire : Ah, mon fils a perdu son papy, est-ce que vous n'auriez pas un livre sur la mort ?
Ah, papa et maman se séparent, est-ce que vous auriez un livre sur... ? Ah, en classe, il y a Trucmuche qui embête Machin, vous n'auriez pas un bouquin sur le harcèlement scolaire.
Et donc au lieu de proposer un peu des modes d'emploi,
on aime plutôt l'idée de proposer des albums riches qui vont permettre à l'enfant de se construire une idée ou une abstraction en tout cas de ces concepts et qui sont
Mh.
ce qui seront ces questions existentielles.
D'ailleurs, dès le plus jeune âge, un album sur le deuil, sur le décès, sur tout ça. Est-ce qu'il y a des sujets où malgré tout, tu estimes qu'il faudrait quand même éviter ou bien est-ce que c'est vraiment carte blanche ?
Alors ça dépend de la qualité de l'album.
Ok.
Voilà. Et donc
Il faut que ce soit quand même pédagogue. Il faut que l'enfant soit pris en compte dans
Oui, faut... bah, c'est surtout
Dans le déroulé quoi.
Plus l'album est bon, mieux ça marchera et plus ça marchera aussi pour l'enfant. Et moi ce que j'aime bien dire aussi, c'est que
Mais il faut que ce soit malgré tout un album qui est pensé pour les enfants.
Ah oui, oui.
Ça peut pas être super
On va pas lui lire Maus par exemple.
Oui, c'est ça.
Voilà, ça non. Mais de la littérature jeunesse, ce sont quand même des gens qui écrivent pour les enfants, des éditeurs d'enfants, etc.
Ok.
Et donc, oui. Et alors moi, ce que j'aime bien penser aussi, c'est que l'enfant reste toujours consentant à la lecture.
Donc c'est-à-dire que, ben, je lui souhaite, c'est que s'il ne veut plus et qu'il a peur, il ferme le livre.
Mh.
Ou il ne veut pas. Et on arrête là. Et si l'enfant exprime qu'il y a quelque chose qui lui est problématique par rapport au livre, de l'expérience de lecture qu'on a avec lui
Oui.
On arrête.
J'ai envie de faire le lien, je sais que c'est, je pars un peu sur autre chose, mais je fais le lien avec
ce qu'on a vu il y a pas si longtemps, il y a un an ou deux, avec les parents qui manifestaient vis-à-vis des cours d'éducation à la vie relationnelle, affective et sexuelle.
Mh.
Avec très fort cette idée de : on ne peut surtout pas parler de sexualité avec les enfants. Alors, je vais au global, donc toutes ces thématiques que tu citais, donc la mort, le décès, les violences, le...
Et donc oui, je vais rajouter à ça la sexualité.
Oui.
Qu'est-ce que ça dit sur une certaine parentalité, un certain mode de parentalité de : on ne va surtout pas exposer nos enfants à tout ça ?
Alors moi, je pense qu'il y a vraiment une croyance qu'il faut préserver l'innocence de l'enfant, que c'est une forme de cire vierge.
On n'a toujours pas quitté le concept-
Innocence qui est largement construite.
Complètement.
Oui, oui.
Complètement. Je pense que les enfants sont bien plus profonds, intelligents, complexes que-
Et bien moins innocents.
Et bien moins innocents. Et heureusement pour eux hein, parce que quand même, voilà, parce que c'est surtout très creux hein, des petits anges.
C'est ça.
Voilà, voilà. Et donc... Oui, moi, je réfute tout à fait cette idée et je réfute l'idée qu'il faille protéger les enfants de tout un tas de thématiques.
Donc par exemple, moi, je fais des séances de prévention à la violence sexuelle au travers d'albums jeunesse dans des classes de maternelle.
D'accord.
Dès la deuxième maternelle. On peut effectivement lire et faire de la prévention, parce que je distingue nettement sexualité et violence sexuelle hein.
Bien sûr.
C'est pas du tout la même chose. Et-
Est-ce qu'on peut parler de violence sexuelle sans étaler les bases de la sexualité ?
Alors, ça dépend tout à fait avec quel public, mais je pense effectivement avec les enfants. Moi, je pense par exemple à...
Alors oui, parce que les gosses de l'aide à la jeunesse-
Oui.
Vont arriver dans les institutions avec vraisemblablement, statistiquement, un background de violence-
Oui, un vécu.
Plus un vécu que les enfants tout venant des classes de maternelle vont avoir. Donc je n'adapterai pas les mêmes, 'fin, je ne ferai pas la chose de la même manière.
Mh.
Mais par exemple, si on fait une séance de prévention autour de l'album jeunesse qui va traiter des questions de violence, qu'elles soient sexuelles ou psychologiques ou autres, on peut tout à fait lire un album.
Donc, je pense par exemple à Petit Doux n'a pas peur, sans aborder la question de la sexualité. Parce qu'un enfant victime de violence va peut-être pouvoir comprendre quelque chose, de se dire
: Mais tiens, le loup, il est quand même un peu chelou.
Enfin, c'est vrai, moi, ça me fait quand même penser à machin, machin. Et ça va répercuter quelque chose en lui.
Un enfant qui n'est pas victime de violence, il va juste voir un loup méchant avec un ours. Donc ça ne va pas mettre dans la tête de l'enfant des idées.
Il ne va pas s'imaginer qu'il a vécu quelque chose. Ça, pour moi, c'est vraiment une fausse croyance. Comme quand on entend : Tiens, on va aller faire des cours d'EVRAS, les enfants vont tous avoir envie de devenir non binaires.
Ah oui, oui.
Voilà. Vous parliez tout à l'heure, enfin, tu parlais tout à l'heure des cours d'EVRAS, mais c'est des choses qu'on peut entendre.
Oui, oui.
Ils vont tous avoir envie de changer de genre ou ils vont tous dire qu'ils ont vécu de la violence sexuelle si c'est ça dont on parle.
Et en fait, moi, je pense vraiment que ce ne sont pas des idées. Enfin, ce n'est pas vrai.
Non, mais c'est, oui, c'est au-delà de la pensée, c'est juste, il y a rien qui corrobore ça.
Non.
Vraiment.
Il y a beaucoup d'études-
C'est les contre-
Qui sont faites sur les fausses allégations d'abus. Et il y a beaucoup plus de publications qui sont faites sur les fausses allégations d'abus que, statistiquement, sur le nombre d'enfants victimes de violences.
Mh, mh. Oui.
Donc il y a malheureusement des études qui corroborent parfois ce type de pensée.
Oui. Et donc voilà, donc si tu développes cette idée qu'il ne faut pas avoir peur d'en parler, il faut en parler donc avec les bons supports.
Oui.
De bonne manière, s'adapter vis-à-vis de son public. Alors, je sais que c'est pas le sujet, mais j'ai envie de faire le lien avec encore autre chose.
Ok.
Mais, parce qu'on parlait il y a un instant de cette innocence largement construite, etc.
Oui.
On parle de sexualité. En France, et même aux États-Unis, il y a régulièrement cette idée de : il faut protéger les mineurs de la pornographie.
Ok.
Il ne faut pas les exposer à ça. Et j'ai toujours trouvé que ça touchait aussi à ça, cette idée de : ils sont très innocents, il faut les garder purs comme ils sont, ne pas les exposer à du contenu, etc.
Comment est-ce que tu vois ça ?
Oui, encore cette idée de pureté qui-
Oui, c'est ça.
Alors, c'est une question compliquée.
Oui, je sais.
Je trouve que c'est une question compliquée.
Donc si on reprend, par exemple, plutôt la question de la domination dans la violence sexuelle, de dire que la violence sexuelle, c'est pas tant une question de sexualité, mais c'est une question de domination.
Les contenus pornographiques sont quand même largement orientés domination, quand même. Et donc, proposer-- donc si l'enfant est-- non, ou le jeune hein.
Oui, on parle des adolescents à ce moment-là.
Ou des ados quoi. Effectivement, un gosse de six ans, on va pas mater du porno. Enfin, ça, ça ne va pas.
On n'espère pas, non.
Voilà. Là, ce serait effectivement problématique et c'est une forme de violence d'exposer un enfant à ce type de-
Sans aucun doute.
Mais voilà, les ados, c'est quand même proposé-- enfin, l'ado est quand même confronté ou observe en tout cas des rapports sexuels, de la sexualité qui est mue par de la domination.
Oui, problématique, souvent. Pas forcément, mais souvent.
Pas forcément. Je dis majoritairement, effectivement, avec des scènes, voilà, avec
plusieurs personnes ou je n'ai pas exactement les termes, mais des trucs, des bukkakes, par exemple, où tous les hommes vont éja-- tous les hommes vont éjaculer sur une femme.
On est quand même dans un truc-
Ou des discours, des façons dont les personnes vont se parler entre elles.
Voilà, des fellations très profondes, des choses, voilà. C'est pas...
Il y a régulièrement de l'inceste.
Oui, en plus, ça, j'ai vu qu'il y avait une recrudescence au niveau de la pornographie, des recherches qui sont en lien avec des mises en scène d'inceste.
C'est questionnant, voilà.
Alors, ce que j'ai lu à ce sujet,
je sais pas pourquoi j'ai lu ça, mais j'ai lu à ce sujet que autrefois, il y avait, par exemple, du tabou à l'idée de dire : le plombier,
on va coucher avec le plombier, mais comme c'est inimaginable, ou le livreur de pizza, c'est jamais vu.
Et puis, au fil des années, au fil de, voilà, je parlais d'émancipation et de libération des mœurs, ça a cessé d'être choquant dans l'inconscient collectif, le fait de dire : oui, bah oui, pourquoi pas le livreur de pizza.
Et au final, pour créer cette idée de tabou et d'interdit et de c'est pas tout à fait bien, le beau-frère.
Ah ouais.
Alors, c'est pas du vrai, vrai, vrai-
Donc ils ont reconstruit un genre de-
C'est pas du vrai, vrai inceste parce qu'ils sont pas vraiment frères.
Non, oui, parce que ce sont des acteurs porno.
Oui, c'est ça. Mais les personnages, ce ne sont pas vraiment frères et sœurs.
Ouais.
Ils sont beau-frère, belle-sœur. Et donc on recrée un petit peu cette idée de tabou et de hmm, on ne devrait pas. C'est ce que j'ai pu entendre.
Ouais, ouais, ouais. Je sais pas...
C'est compliqué.
Oui, c'est compliqué. Je vais avoir une idée, mais plus tard.
Si, si, si c'est pas ton-
Oui, non, mais c'est pas-
Si t'as pas de réponse claire.
Non, ça-
Mais pour revenir donc à vraiment la question des adolescents qu'on a surtout envie de préserver de tout ça, j'ai toujours trouvé qu'il y avait vraiment un rapport très paternaliste quoi, de,
on va dire, à des gens qui ont 16, 17 ans, qu'on sait mieux qu'eux comment aborder la sexualité alors que-
Comme si nous, on savait déjà hein.
Oui, déjà, et en plus, il y a des gens beaucoup plus vieux que ça qui ne sont pas forcément en position de dire comment bien aborder ces questions. Donc...
Tout à fait.
Bon, voilà.
Et les jeunes, alors, c'est un peu une formule un peu éculée, mais les jeunes d'aujourd'hui, moi, je trouve qu'on le voit super fort dans les séries Netflix, etc.
Ou Sex Education, etc. On voit quand même que les jeunes sont dans un rapport qui est très différent à la sexualité que même, je veux dire, la génération juste au-dessus.
Qu'est-ce que tu observes à ce niveau-là ?
Bah, en tout cas, par rapport à la question effectivement du-- alors, ça dépend quel type de population, puisque je pense qu'effectivement, les jeunes qui sont montrés, exposés, mis en scène dans les séries Netflix,
c'est pas les jeunes qui habitent dans les quartiers,
euh,
plus pauvres ou les gosses issus de l'aide à la jeunesse hein.
C'est une question de capital culturel, d'éducation, on a tout ça, ouais.
Et donc, là, je trouve qu'effectivement, j'ai la sensation que dans ce type de milieu, voilà, la question du genre, la question du...
Du consentement.
Du consentement, la question, voilà, c'est quand même beaucoup plus sur la table. Enfin, moi, j'avais 15 ans en 2000.
Le consentement, ça n'existait pas. On n'en a jamais parlé.
J'ai déjà pu entendre ça.
Jamais. Et donc moi et mes amis, on en a déjà beaucoup parlé. On a découvert la violence et la contrainte après l'avoir vécue parce qu'on ne savait pas que ça existait.
Et c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il faut absolument éduquer les enfants. Parce qu'à partir du moment où ils sont au courant que la violence sexuelle, que la violence ou que le harcèlement existent, ils pourront reconnaître la situation.
Si les enfants, on ne leur explique pas, si on les laisse purs, innocents, ils vont jamais détecter une situation qui est problématique.
Hmm, hmm. Et donc vis-à-vis spécifiquement de ce que je décrivais comme étant un certain paternalisme vis-à-vis des jeunes, vis-à-vis des adolescents.
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose que tu as tendance à observer vraiment des adultes, des personnes plus âgées qui
savent mieux, qui pensent savoir mieux, qui pensent être légitimes de contrôler finalement un certain accès à la sexualité, à la pornographie ?
Oui, mais même dans l'absolu, par rapport à tout, je trouve que quelque part, l'enfant ou l'ado n'a pas véritablement de place dans la société pour pouvoir être ce qu'il est.
Je trouve quand on dit : « Ce sont les citoyens de demain ». C'est une formule qui m'énerve parce que c'est pas les citoyens de demain.
Ils vivent avec nous, là, ici, avec nous. Donc, voilà.
Ils ont pu voter finalement entre seize et dix-huit ans, je ne sais plus.
L'Europe, je crois, juste.
Oui, c'est ça, juste pour l'Europe. Donc, ils ont le droit de voter. Ils n'ont pas le droit d'accéder à la pornographie.
Ils peuvent voter pour l'Europe, un truc quand même vachement compliqué.
Et important, oui.
Mais que ce soit les ados, que ce soit les enfants, il y a une logique extrêmement paternaliste, rien-- 'fin, aussi par rapport
à comment fonctionne un enfant, 'fin, comment est-ce qu'il doit être, comment est-ce qu'il doit se tenir à table, 'fin.
Et ce paternalisme, voilà, je vais reprendre le mot, est très présent dans les contextes scolaires, les contextes d'internat, sujet auquel on va arriver dans un instant.
Donc tu as travaillé ou tu es spécialisée largement sur la question des enfants mis en internat, donc dans des contextes très particuliers.
Oui, placés en internat scolaire par l'aide à la jeunesse.
Oui, c'est ça, voilà. Est-ce que tu peux nous parler un petit peu de tes expériences vis-à-vis de ça ? Donc c'est quelque chose-- est-ce que c'est des situations que tu observes régulièrement, très régulièrement au quotidien ?
Oui. Alors, on parle souvent, 'fin, il y a un des concepts, je dis tout le temps concept. Un des trucs qu'on observe beaucoup.
J'aime bien le fait que tu aies remplacé le mot concept par truc. C'est mon-- mon vocabulaire est un peu creux, je dis truc.
Bref.
On est bizarres, on est drôles.
On a beaucoup vu à la télé qu'il y avait des bébés placés en hôpital, par exemple. Ça, on en parle beaucoup. Ah ben oui, y a pas de place dans les institutions, on ne sait pas quoi faire avec tous ces enfants de l'aide à la jeunesse.
Et il y a des bébés qui sont placés à l'hôpital.
Mais ça, c'est une petite pointe parce que il y a de ceux-là, mais ça, c'est ceux qui vont vraiment très très très mal et qui peut-être que s'ils ne vont pas à l'hôpital, ils vont mourir.
Parlons des choses vraiment. Mais il y a aussi tous les autres enfants dont on ne sait que faire parce qu'il n'y a pas de place dans des institutions spécialisées.
Et une des solutions, c'est de les mettre en internat scolaire. Ces internats scolaires ne sont pas du tout des structures qui sont faites pour accueillir des gosses qui ont les vécus qu'ils ont.
Ils n'ont pas de moyens, très peu d'éducateurs, pas de sous, pas de structure. Et ils se retrouvent avec une population à 99,9 % de gosses de l'aide à la jeunesse.
Mais à côté de ça, il y a d'autres internats où voilà, où il y a vraiment des parents qui ont les moyens.
Ah oui, oui.
Voilà, les trucs catholiques dans le Brabant.
Oui, oui, mais ça, oui, ça, t'en doutes pas que oui, effectivement. Ça, c'est pas ceux-là avec lesquels j'ai travaillé.
Y a pas de placement là-bas, tiens.
Y a pas de placement, peut-être. Mais oui, ce sont des structures. C'est vrai qu'effectivement, c'est vrai qu'il y a des grosses structures plutôt chicos.
Ça, c'est pas le même truc. Dans lequel, à mon avis, je suis sûre qu'il y a aussi des questions de violence sexuelle entre mineurs, soit dit en passant, à mon avis.
Tu dis ça...
Je dis ça au niveau des statistiques parce que c'est vraiment une situation qui est statistiquement courante et qu'il y a des chances que ce soit des situations qui se sont déjà passées.
Oui. Et donc tu dis il y a des chances, parce que je présume que ce n'est pas forcément enregistré, répertorié.
Voilà.
Que le staff ne fait pas nécessairement son travail à ce niveau-là.
Bien sûr.
Qu'il y a une omerta sur ces questions.
Oui. Mais alors une omerta à multi-niveaux. Vraiment une silenciation transversale. Oui, oui. La victime est-elle en possession de comprendre ce qui lui est arrivé ?
S'en rappelle-t-elle ? Est-ce qu'elle a une amnésie traumatique ? Est-ce que, donc, donc au niveau psychologique. Ensuite, est-ce qu'elle a parlé ?
Est-ce qu'elle a été entendue ? Est-ce qu'elle a été crue ? Je genre au féminin parce que c'est statistiquement plus souvent, en tout cas à l'adolescence,
parce que les enfants victimes de violences sexuelles, il y a aussi énormément de garçons.
Et là, tu parles de, encore une fois, entre enfants ou de manière générale ?
Alors, entre enfants, il y a beaucoup de violences sexuelles entre garçons.
D'accord.
Ouais. Et alors, mais alors là, ce sont vraiment des observations que moi, j'ai faites. Donc, il y a zéro truc stat, étude, ni rien.
C'est limite anecdotique, quoi. C'est ton observation.
Oui, c'est moi qui ai la sensation que les filles, les enfants filles, ados filles, peuvent agresser sexuellement.
Et puis, plus elles vont grandir, moins elles vont continuer à perpétrer ce comportement et plus devenir victimes, tandis que les garçons peuvent continuer à agresser.
Donc, il y a plus de jeunes filles et d'enfants agresseuses que de femmes agresseuses. Vous voyez ? Ouais.
Oui oui. Comment est-ce que tu expliques ça ?
Bah, je ne sais pas, moi. Une de mes hypothèses, c'est que sociétalement, il y a une construction d'un vécu plus, plus de la place de victime pour la femme.
D'accord. Et la place du dominant pour l'homme.
Ouais. Maintenant, c'est vraiment, c'est ma petite hypothèse.
Elle est crédible hein.
Voilà, ça se tient, mais comme je dis, j'ai aucune... Voilà, c'est une sensation que j'ai. C'est une sensation que j'ai.
Et donc les placements, tu disais assez peu de budget.
Oui oui voilà, c'est de ça dont on parlait.
Dans ces institutions-là. Qu'est-ce que ça a comme répercussions, concrètement, sur le vécu des enfants là-bas ?
Alors, donc moi, je suis arrivée là un peu par hasard... J'avais envie de travailler dans l'aide à la jeunesse.
C'est pas un hasard puisque tu mettais des Playmobil dans les hôpitaux et dans les orphelinats.
C'est vrai.
Voilà.
Tout est lié.
C'est vrai que c'était pas tout à fait un hasard. Mais un jour, on m'a téléphoné en me disant : Tiens, est-ce que tu aurais de la place pour un gosse, pour un suivi ?
Et alors, j'ai dit : Oui, oui. Et on m'a dit : Mais en fait, il faudrait y aller.
Mmm-hmm.
Est-ce que tu serais d'accord d'aller à l'internat ? Et moi, j'ai dit : OK. Parce que j'étais jeune et énergique. Et donc j'ai rempli une valise de matériel, de Playmobil, évidemment, des Kapla, des livres, des machins.
J'ai pris ma petite valise et je suis allée dans l'internat scolaire et j'ai commencé à avoir des enfants.
Et j'ai commencé à faire de la thérapie au long cours avec ces enfants. Et donc, je suis sortie du cabinet du psy, hein, le sacro-saint cabinet du psy, pour aller dans le milieu de vie.
Donc, très grande question : Peut-on faire de la thérapie dans un milieu de vie ? Est-ce que c'est un milieu neutre ?
Comment est-ce qu'on fait ? Enfin-
Mmm.
Toutes ces questions pour revenir alors à la question du cadre, de la psychanalyse.
Donc c'était toujours en one to one ou bien c'était...
Oui.
Ouais, OK.
Oui. Donc ça, c'était des questions très intéressantes aussi parce qu'on sortait un peu le psy de la tour d'ivoire pour aller un peu mettre les mains dans...
Dans le cambouis.
Ben dans le cambouis ou pour préparer les tartines et faire les lits, enfin dans le quotidien des enfants quoi.
D'accord, OK.
Et...
Et c'est dans ce quotidien-là, en préparant les livres et les tartines que tu discutais un peu avec chacun ?
Non, en fait, je,
j'exagère un peu en disant que je faisais les tartines, mais je pense-- c'est parce que par là, j'ai envie de pouvoir dire que les éducateurs qui s'occupent des jeunes,
même si parfois, on pense qu'ils sont dans une logistique, toute cette logistique fait soin.
Donc moi, je proposais des thérapies, effectivement, dans des classes à part. On a fait ça dans des salles de jeux, dans des cagibis, dans des gymnases.
Et donc ça-- mais le quotidien que les éducateurs, voilà, entretiennent avec les enfants est aussi, à mon sens, tout à fait de l'ordre du soin quoi.
Et donc ce que j'observe avec ces enfants-là, c'est que, c'est comme ça que j'ai appelé l'article, c'est « Placés, pas tout à fait ».
C'est une forme d'alternative entre des enfants qui sont dans des contextes qui sont parfois dangereux, maltraitants, et qui, pour certains, ont une bulle de répit pendant une semaine et tous les vendredis, ils rentrent à la maison.
Mmm.
Maintenant, il y a des enfants pour qui c'est une bonne-- c'est un bon ratio où ils sont à l'internat, ils peuvent aller à l'école, veiller une routine.
Et puis les week-ends, ben c'est relativement safe à la maison et ça va s'ils rentrent quoi. Mais il y a quand même des enfants auxquels on a des sueurs froides en se disant
: « Il va rentrer, il va rentrer ce week-end, qu'est-ce qui va bien pouvoir se passer ? »
Mmm. Ah oui, parce que le milieu familial...
Parce que le milieu-- et que l'internat scolaire ne permet pas un accueil vingt-quatre sur vingt-quatre, sept jours sur sept quoi.
Et c'est pas forcément quelque chose qu'on pourrait souhaiter, hein, je pense... Tu sais. Alors, j'ai été en internat pendant un petit mois.
Un petit mois.
Voilà, et je fais régulièrement la comparaison avec des milieux carcéraux, moi.
Mmm.
Je trouve, je trouve c'est beaucoup de murs, beaucoup de béton et pas beaucoup de verre.
Alors, c'est... Ça dé-- alors, je me dis ça dépend lesquels, mais c'est vrai que l'institution, c'est quand même, je veux dire, architecturalement et tout, c'est quand même l'institution quoi, il y a quelque chose où...
Ce qui m'avait frappé, moi, c'était aussi
le fait que je pouvais discuter avec d'autres élèves à cet endroit-là et je pouvais discuter du dernier film, du dernier livre, dernière musique, dernière série ou quoi.
Et tout le monde me disait : « Ah non, je sais pas. Je reste tout le temps ici, moi, je peux pas. »
Ouais.
Et donc il y a cette espèce de vie, d'absence de culture-
Ah oui.
Qui est très triste en fait.
Ah oui, ça, c'est clair.
Très glauque. Beaucoup de tabagisme aussi dans ce milieu-là.
Oui, oui.
Ouais, donc ça réveille des souvenirs absolument odieux. Mais- Attends. Et donc je partais d'où en disant ça ?
Oui, oui, est-ce qu'on pourrait sou-- ouais. Je ne souhaiterais à personne de rester dans un internat sept jours sur sept.
Non, ça dépend ce qu'ils vivent à la maison hein.
Voilà, oui.
Parce que bon, avec des gosses qui sont soumis à des violences, des violences sexuelles ou des situations avec de la consommation ou...
Oui, c'est la super grosse question.
Mmm.
Maintenant, moi, je pense qu'à partir d'un moment, il faut protéger les enfants.
Et donc il faut les sortir de ces milieux qui les maltraitent.
Mmm.
Et si on pouvait avoir un petit peu plus de sous pour rendre les internats un peu plus cosy, ce serait bien.
Avec une télé, avec un jacuzzi...
Ben plus de personnel, plus d'encadrement, que la relation à l'adulte puisse être, puisse, voilà, soignée.
Mais c'est vrai que la question de la culture avec les gosses de l'aide à la jeunesse, ça, évidemment, c'est... Oui, c'est un autre pan.
Ouais, ouais. Et donc le lien que tu faisais tout à l'heure entre la surreprésentation, le fait qu'on observe régulièrement les violences sexuelles entre mineurs, donc dans ces endroits-là, c'est quoi la cause ?
Le fait que-- C'est le public ? C'est le lieu ? C'est le béton ? Qu'est-ce qui fait que...
Ouais. Alors moi, j'ai plusieurs idées, mais encore une fois, hein, c'est ma pratique qui guide, voilà, qui guide des impressions.
Ouais.
Et donc voilà, je suis absolument pas ici pour scander des vérités et dire moi, je sais que c'est comme ça.
Non, on vient écouter ton récit.
Donc moi, je pense que les enfants de l'aide à la jeunesse ont statistiquement beaucoup plus de risques d'avoir vécu des violences. Qu'elles soient avérées ou non, qu'elles soient entendues ou non.
Donc on sait qu'un enfant sur dix est victime de violence sexuelle, dans la majorité, dans la population tout venant, pour l'aide à la jeunesse, c'est, on est beaucoup beaucoup plus élevé.
Et donc, on sait que le plus grand facteur de risque de vivre de la violence sexuelle, c'est d'avoir vécu de la violence sexuelle.
Mh. On réitère.
On ré-- ouais, ah, c'est très, c'est compliqué. Est-ce qu'on réitère pour une multitude de choses ? Est-ce qu'on reproduit ?
Est-ce qu'on reçu-- enfin, y a plein de choses, mais c'est un facteur de risque, en tout cas.
Corrélation, quoi.
Ouais. Parce que j'ai pas envie de dire : « Ah ouais, t'as vécu, donc direct, tu vas revivre ou tu vas faire subir. » Y a une multitude de choses qui l'expliquent.
Maintenant, c'est le plus grand facteur de risque, c'est d'en avoir vécu. Donc ça, c'est une chose. Et donc, on les met tous ensemble, quoi, quelque part. Et je pense
que si on reprend l'hypothèse de la domination, qui, à mon sens, est une des choses qui va expliquer les passages à l'acte et la nécessité de passer à l'acte, ok, donc à un moment de devoir dominer
avec l'arme la plus redoutable qui est le viol,
je pense que ces institutions dans lesquelles les enfants sont mis tous ensemble et vivent tous ensemble avec des structures hiérarchiques puissantes,
et des enfants qui sont aussi, par la force des choses, hein, je jette la pierre à personne, c'est vraiment systémique, mais qui ont très peu de pouvoir d'agir et de pouvoir de choix.
Hein. Ils choisissent jamais ce qu'ils mangent, ils choisissent pas quand ils se lavent, ils choisissent pas leur chambre, ils choisissent pas leurs vêtements.
Enfin, je veux dire, c'est quand même des enfants institutionnalisés, donc ils ont pas d'espace de liberté, y a pas d'espace de création.
D'où la comparaison carcérale que je faisais tout à l'heure.
Tout à fait. Oui, exactement. Et donc, je pense que c'est des enfants qui, parfois, ont la nécessité pour survivre de devoir dominer.
Prendre du pouvoir.
Prendre le pouvoir.
Ouais.
Et que c'est une des armes qui est à leur portée parce que c'est quelque chose qu'ils ont connu et qu'ils savent que ça marche.
C'est une idée, mais je pense que c'est effectivement-
Se crée vraiment.
Ouais. Et alors y a quelque chose autour. On parlait tout à l'heure du tabou, de l'omerta, etc. Y a quelque chose effectivement qui, la silenciation autour de la violence sexuelle va générer sa perpétuation.
Y a quelque chose qui fait que ça-
Ils ont constaté que dans leur cas, on-
On n'en a jamais rien fait.
L'agresseur n'a pas forcément eu énormément de problèmes. Donc, ils comprennent que, bon...
Ils intériorisent-
Ouais
...tout à fait que c'est silencié.
C'est ça.
Et donc, mais donc ça marche dans les deux sens parce que qu'ils agissent les actes ou qu'ils les subissent, hein.
Parce que souvent, c'est un melting pot, hein, ils passent de l'un à l'autre, hein.
C'est ça. Et donc ça, c'est spécifiquement vis-à-vis de personnes qui ont été à un moment donné victimes d'agressions sexuelles.
Est-ce qu'on observe aussi une tendance à faire plus d'agressions sexuelles entre mineurs dans les internats, chez un public qui n'a jamais connu ça ?
Alors, je n'ai aucune donnée sur la question. J'ai jamais travaillé dans des-
T'as surtout travaillé avec des personnes qui ont été victimes.
Oui. Donc, voilà. Et dans la grosse grosse majorité des situations, si-- parce que j'ai pas envie de dire toutes parce que ça fait un peu, mais,
mais les gosses qui sont dans des situations de violence entre mineurs ont un passé.
Mh.
Maintenant, si on prend un internat scolaire qui n'est pas composé de gosses de l'aide à la jeunesse, on est quand même sur une population tout venant, avec quand même un enfant sur dix victime de violence sexuelle.
Si on fait le calcul de combien est-ce que, du coup, ça fait d'enfants dans un internat tout venant, bah le risque est là quand même, il est juste diminué, quoi.
Oui, oui. Alors, on va parler de ton livre dans un instant quand même.
Oui, c'est pour ça que je suis là.
Mais aussi, oui. Mais est-ce que tu aimerais rajouter quelque chose sur toutes les questions qu'on a évoquées ?
Est-ce qu'on est passé à côté de quelque chose d'essentiel ?
Je sais pas trop. En tout cas, d'insister effectivement sur la question de cette silenciation, et que
plus on parlera des choses, plus on pourra protéger les enfants, je pense. En tout cas, je disais un truc quand je travaillais avec les équipes, elles me disaient toujours : « Mais c'est horrible ce que tu dis ».
Le plan, c'est pas qu'ils ne soient pas violés. Le plan, c'est qu'ils soient violés moins longtemps. C'est horrible. Oui, mais c'est parce qu'on n'a pas la prétention de se faire, hop, ça s'arrange.
Mais si, à un moment, on arrive effectivement à donner des outils, des clés aux professionnels et aux enfants pour qu'ils puissent parler et être entendus,
décoder les stigmates, décoder les symptômes, essayer de comprendre ce qui se passe, bah, je pense que ce serait bien pour tout le monde.
Ouais. Et est-ce que tu observes une tendance à l'amélioration vis-à-vis de cette silenciation, vis-à-vis de ces préoccupations ou ?
Oui, un peu quand même.
Un peu quand même.
Bah, par exemple. Bah oui, un peu. S'il y a un exemple assez concret, c'est qu'il est possible aujourd'hui de proposer des formations sur la question de la violence sexuelle en institution.
Donc y en a qui sont données, pour les travailleurs. Chose qui n'existait absolument pas il y a dix ans ou il y a quinze ans, où le titre de l'article était
: Étude d'une dyade, machin, machin, où finalement le titre de mon article était en soi silencié,
même dans son titre.
Donc, il y a dix, quinze ans, même en parler dans des articles scientifiques, c'est compliqué. Et aujourd'hui, on propose des formations pour les travailleurs.
Donc, je trouve que ça montre quand même une forme d'évolution.
Mh. Mh. Donc ton livre.
Ouais.
Entre deux rives, publié donc chez Parlat éditions. Ça se passe à Liège.
C'est relativement rare.
Ah ouais ?
Souvent, les nouvelles autrices, nouveaux auteurs ont tendance à dire : « On va quand même essayer de toucher un public français.
Ah ouais.
On est soixante-dix. On va dire que ça se passe à Paris ou dans une banlieue quelque part, etc. Tu aimes beaucoup ta ville, j'ai l'impression.
En lisant ton livre, j'ai l'impression que tu aimes beaucoup ta ville.
J'aime beaucoup ma ville. Beaucoup, beaucoup. Les Liégeois aiment beaucoup leur ville. On est un peu chauvin.
J'ai cru comprendre. OK, donc c'est, voilà, c'est simplement, tu es Liégeoise donc tu aimes ta ville. Y a pas un rapport particulier.
Ça ne va pas plus loin que ça.
Mais si, mais c'est parce que Liège, il y a quelque chose où elle est... C'était une belle métaphore pour le contenu du livre aussi, parce qu'elle est à la fois-
Les deux rives.
Ouais. Alors, mais à la fois les deux rives, oui, le fleuve, effectivement, mais aussi parce qu'elle est... Elle est crasseuse et délicieuse.
Elle est magnifique et elle est un peu puante, quoi. Enfin, c'est Liège, quoi. C'est, c'est, c'est... voilà.
Est-ce qu'elle est magnifique quand on est Liégeois ou est-ce qu'elle est magnifique pour tout le monde ?
Je pense que si on la visite, je... Elle est pas forte pour plaire au premier regard.
Ok.
Surtout pas ces derniers temps avec les travaux du tram, mais c'est fini. Mais vraiment, là, on a vraiment cru qu'on allait tous mourir.
C'est toujours un challenge quand on parle de Liège avec des Liégeois.
Est-ce qu'on va parler du tram ?
Mais c'est fini maintenant.
Ouais, c'est fini.
Voilà.
Mais c'était, franchement, c'était dur hein.
C'était dur.
Ah ouais, c'était glauque, c'était terrible. Franchement, c'était hard.
Mmh.
C'était hard. Tous les rats sortaient et tout. Franchement, c'était hard. Non, vraiment, vraiment. Parce qu'ils ont tout cassé dans... Ah non, des souvenirs.
On va écarter le sujet du tram.
On va écarter du tram.
Je sens que-
Mais cela dit, c'est magnifique. C'est super, ce tram, c'est, c'est-
Bah voilà.
On a tous-
Ça valait le coup.
Oui, oui, ça valait le coup. Non, ça, clairement. Et loin de moi l'idée de râler sur le fait... Non, c'est que...
il y a quelque chose dans son cœur, dans son... il y a quelque chose qui vibre. Je sais pas expliquer.
C'est Liège.
Ouais, y a quelque chose de... Voilà, il y a une vie culturelle, y a... mais y a une tendresse, quoi. Y a quelque chose.
Mais donc ma question, c'est : est-ce que cette tendresse, cet amour, etc., c'est parce que tu es Liégeoise ?
Mais ça, je ne sais pas. Moi, j'aimerais bien dire que non, mais en fait, c'est pas à moi qu'il faut demander, parce que moi, c'est-
Faut demander aux autres.
Mes parents ont quitté Bruxelles pour venir vivre à Liège.
Voilà, c'est quand même pas mal ça.
Voilà. Mais je saurais jamais répondre ça, parce que...
Ok, mais donc en tout cas, il y a chez toi un amour profond pour ta ville qui fait que c'était inimaginable de placer le récit ailleurs.
Mais ce qu'il y a, c'est que le récit s'est un peu construit de lui-même, donc j'ai jamais vraiment réfléchi de savoir si ça allait être là ou ailleurs, parce que c'était cette histoire-là qui se passait là.
Oui, et c'est largement inspiré de tes propres expériences-
Ouais.
Ce qui se passait là.
Tout à fait.
Ouais, ouais. Et donc voilà, on peut révéler un petit peu l'intrigue. Donc ça démarre avec un incendie.
Mh.
Et donc une maman et son fils qui se retrouvent à ne plus avoir de domicile. Il faut les placer quelque part.
Ouais.
Et la maman a donc quelques difficultés à générer des revenus, à s'occuper, selon les services sociaux, efficacement, correctement de son enfant.
J'imagine que ça, c'est des situations auxquelles t'étais confrontée toi-même.
Oui, tout à fait.
Ouais.
Et en plus, là, comme tu en parles, c'est un peu édulcoré parce que-
Oui, c'est très-
Elle consomme aussi de la drogue hein, c'est sûr et certain. On boit quand même beaucoup de bière.
Mh.
Oui, tout à fait. Évidemment, ça, c'est tout à fait... Et alors, la question, alors, c'est vraiment la question compliquée de la parentalité.
C'est : est-ce qu'on est dans une parentalité qui pose problème ou pas ? Est-ce que la pauvreté-
Et qui est ton processeur ?
Et qui... ouais. Bah, et donc c'est là, effectivement, qu'il est intéressant de pouvoir questionner les enfants et s'adresser vraiment au vécu de l'enfant.
Oui, c'est quelque chose qu'on ressent très fort dans ce que tu développes comme propos, mine de rien, à travers le livre, c'est le fait que l'enfant n'est pas écouté, ne se sent pas écouté.
Il y a une petite rage chez lui par rapport à ça.
Oui, et je pense qu'il faut... enfin, c'est vraiment à observer l'enfant, que ce soit ses symptômes ou ce qui va bien, ce qui va pas bien, qu'on va savoir si la parentalité est efficiente ou pas.
Parce que... Et c'est vrai que souvent, on observe qu'on travaille plus avec l'adulte, mais c'est quand même intéressant de savoir comment est-ce que l'enfant se sent.
Mh, mh, mh. Il finit, y a un placement de l'enfant, hein, Aldo-
Oui.
Dans un internat. Il est pas hyper fan, il... bon, il finit par s'y accommoder. Voilà, on va pas trop révéler ce qui se passe, mais qu'est-ce qui t'a amenée, finalement, à écrire ce livre ?
C'est une frustration par rapport aux situations que tu observais ? Quelque chose que... Une incompréhension que tu observais chez le grand public ?
Oh non, pas du tout.
Non ?
Ah non. Non, c'était pas... C'était plutôt... C'était plutôt des sentiments positifs qui m'ont donné envie d'écrire ce récit, ce truc, cette espèce d'OVNI hybride.
Ce concept.
Ce truc, oui, voilà, c'est ça, ce concept. J'avais envie de...
Oui, de mettre à l'honneur les gens avec lesquels on travaille, de mettre à l'honneur les enfants, et de mettre à l'honneur aussi la tendresse de l'intimité qu'on partage avec ces gens.
C'est marrant parce que j'avais justement l'impression qu'à travers le regard de l'enfant, voilà, les collègues dont tu parles, les travailleurs, les...
oui, les gens des services sociaux étaient souvent assez frustrés vis-à-vis de... Non ?
Ah, c'est marrant, tiens. C'est...
Les porteurs de mauvaises nouvelles, quoi, finalement.
Oui, mais alors frustrés. Non, oui. Ah oui, non, d'accord. Je fais le chemin dans ma tête, j'ai compris. L'impuissance est terrible.
Oui, c'est ça.
Voilà. Donc l'impuissance des travailleurs sociaux, c'est terrible. C'est, voilà, c'est vraiment...
C'est très difficile, et une des choses qui protège, je dirais, de l'effondrement, c'est la tendresse et c'est les petits morceaux d'humanité.
Parce que sinon-
C'est intéressant parce que justement, les scènes où il est jugé que la maman ne fait pas très bien son travail, etc.
Je la trouve très froide et pas très humaine.
Ah oui, le personnage. Oui, d'accord, je vois. Oui, mais je pense qu'il y a certains travailleurs sociaux qui se blindent.
Ah oui, oui.
Parce que faut aussi imaginer que les personnes qui sont dans des postes plus de décisions, qui doivent décider s'ils placent, s'ils placent pas, etc.
Ils ont des listes d'attente absolument catastrophiques avec cinq cents enfants qui attendent des lits, qui sont confrontés toute la journée.
Faut qu'on s'imagine que ce sont des rendez-vous qui s'enchaînent avec à chaque fois des situations de cet ordre-là.
Peut-être parfois, effectivement, faut déconnecter deux, trois petits fusibles dans un, de, ouais, je sais pas, de chaleur ou je sais pas quoi.
Peut-être simplement pour résister à la journée quoi.
Mh.
Parce qu'on n'a pas de solution pour ces enfants.
Et donc parallèlement, donc c'est toute la question des deux rives, parallèlement à l'histoire de
cette famille, voilà, qui connaît une situation très difficile et qui se fait séparer mine de rien pendant la semaine quand il peut aller en internat.
Parallèlement à tout ça, il y a aussi le vécu de l'assistante sociale, Jeanne.
Ouais.
Qu'est-ce qui t'a amenée à travailler sur ce personnage-là ?
La question de ce qui nous mène à devenir travailleurs sociaux.
Mh.
Parfois, on a l'impression qu'on est destiné à ça, mais en fait, on sait pas du tout pourquoi. Je pense que c'est le cas-
Les Playmobil.
Quoi ? Les Playmobil ? Mais oui, mais t'en réponds toujours pas vraiment à la question de pourquoi. Je pense que Jeanne, elle a embrassé cette carrière-là, mais elle est quand même assez flottante, hein.
Elle sait pas trop où elle en est et elle sait pas trop quoi faire avec tout ce qu'elle reçoit.
Et je pense que c'était aussi pour essayer de travailler sur la... Sur la complexité de... Je sais pas bien comment dire, de questions finalement très, très existentielles, mais très banales.
Enfin, voilà, y a quelque chose, c'est quelqu'un de, c'est pas quelqu'un au destin fou, c'est pas quelqu'un à qui il arrive spécialement beaucoup de choses.
C'est quoi les petites et les grandes questions qu'il a traversées ?
La brutalité du quotidien, les choses auxquelles on doit faire face émotionnellement-
Voilà.
Quand on est dans cette position-là quoi.
Finalement, c'est qu'est-ce qui nous, chacun, enfin, Jeanne, c'est un peu tout le monde, c'est une partie de nous tous quoi.
C'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Comment est-ce qu'on se lève ? Comment est-ce qu'on se lave ? Qu'est-ce qu'on va manger ?
Oui, c'est ça.
Qu'est-ce que-
La terrine au saumon, tout ça.
Ouais.
Mh. Oui, je vois très bien. On peut préciser, malgré tout, faire la publicité de ton livre, que Myriam Leroy a beaucoup aimé ton livre.
Ah oui.
C'est pas une petite—
Non.
C'est pas un petit sponsoring, c'est pas une petite pub, donc c'est...
Ouais.
On peut, voilà—
Ça, c'était effectivement.
Les personnes qui nous écoutent, et elles sont nombreuses, qui ont du respect pour le jugement et le travail de Myriam peuvent—
Tout à fait.
Pouvoir confiance en elle.
Elle m'a, ouais, elle m'a bien...
Elle t'a bien liftée. Elle t'a bien—
Ouais, je suis—
Oui, c'est ça. C'est pour ça que tu travailles—
C'est pour ça que je suis là d'ailleurs.
Ouais, c'est ça, directement.
Tout à fait.
Et donc voilà, on peut rappeler donc Entre deux rives, Suzanne Aubinet, publié chez Parla éditions. Merci beaucoup—
De rien.
Pour ces septante minutes passées ensemble.
Super.
On se dit à très bientôt. Au revoir.
Au revoir.
Voilà, c'est déjà tout pour mon interview avec Suzanne Aubinet. N'hésitez pas à me dire si ça vous a plu. C'est toujours un exercice difficile, hein, de traiter des sujets comme ça.
J'essaie de pas rendre ça trop glauque. On a limité les récits et les exemples. J'avoue qu'en réécoutant, c'est assez particulier d'entendre qu'on se marre en discutant tout ça.
Mais bref, dites-moi, ça m'intéresse vraiment. On se retrouve très vite pour une interview d'un autre romancier belge, Lionel Dricot.
Et prenez soin de vous. Je sais que, voilà, l'avenir s'est assombri brutalement cette semaine, mais promis, ça va aller.
N'oubliez pas de me suivre sur Instagram. C'est là que ça se passe. À très bientôt.